Nous avons donc abouti à un paysage numérique
qui réprime la créativité, la nouveauté
et ce qui fait de nous des êtres humains.
Les médias sociaux sont nés.
Permettent-ils aux gens de tisser des liens entre eux de manière neuve ?
Non, les médias sociaux utilisent nos données
pour prédire nos comportements.
Ou, si ça s'avère nécessaire, pour influencer nos comportements
et nous pousser à agir en concordance avec nos profils statistiques.
L'économie numérique aime-t-elle les gens ?
Non, si vous élaborez un plan d'affaires, que devez-vous faire ?
Éliminer tous les hommes.
Les humains veulent des soins de santé, un salaire, du sens.
Impossible de travailler à grande échelle.
(Rires)
Mêmes nos applis
ne nous sont d'aucun recours pour créer des liens de solidarité.
Sur quel bouton appuie-t-on dans l'appli de transport partagé
pour permettre aux conducteurs de parler de leurs conditions de travail
ou de se syndiquer ?
Même les outils de vidéo-conférence
ne permettent l'établissement d'aucun rapport réel.
Quelle que soit la qualité de la résolution,
on ne peut pas observer si l'iris de notre interlocuteur est dilaté.
Tous ces mécanismes que nous avons développés pour créer des liens,
pendant des centaines de milliers d'années d'évolution,
ne sont plus efficaces.
On ne sait pas si la respiration de l'autre se synchronise à la nôtre.
Les neurones miroirs ne réagissent pas, l'ocytocine ne vous traverse pas
et on ne sait plus ce que signifie créer des liens avec d'autres humains.
Maintenant, la situation est :
« Ils étaient d'accord avec moi, mais m'ont-ils vraiment,
vraiment compris ? »
On ne pense pas que c'est la technologie qui est défaillante.
On pense que c'est l'autre personne.
Même les technologies et les initiatives numériques qui existent
pour promouvoir l'humain,
sont fondamentalement anti-humanistes.
Songez à la blockchain.
La blockchain existe-t-il pour développer une économie humaniste ?
Non, elle ne crée aucune confiance entre les utilisateurs.
La blockchain remplace la confiance d'une manière neuve
et moins transparente.
Et l'enseignement de la programmation ?
L'éducation, c'est très bien, on est pour.
C'est aussi une très bonne idée
de vouloir que les enfants puissent avoir un travail dans un avenir numérique,
et donc, enseignons-leur la programmation.
Mais depuis quand l'éducation vise-t-elle l'emploi ?
L'éducation n'a rien à voir avec ça.
L'éducation vient en récompense d'un travail bien fait.
Le principe d'éducation publique
est fondé sur l'idée que les mineurs, travaillant dans la mine la journée,
pourraient rentrer à la maison et jouir de la dignité
de pouvoir lire un roman et le comprendre.
Ou de l'intelligence pour pouvoir participer à la démocratie.
Quand on en fait un préalable au travail, que faisons-nous en réalité ?
On permet simplement aux entreprises
d'externaliser le coût de formation de leurs salariés.
Le pire de tout est le mouvement pour une technologie humaniste.
J'adore ces gens-là, des repentis,
qui ont extrait les algorithmes des machines à sous de Las Vegas
et encodé dans les médias sociaux pour nous rendre accros.
Ils ont reconnus leurs péchés
et souhaitent rendre la technologie plus humaine.
Le son même de l'expression « technologie humaine »
évoque un poulet fermier, par exemple.
On va essayer d'être aussi humain que possible,
jusqu'au moment de les amener à l'abattoir.
On va rendre ces technologies aussi humaines que possible
tant qu'elles exploitent suffisamment de nos données et d'argent
pour satisfaire les actionnaires.
Entretemps, les actionnaires pensent ceci :
« Je dois gagner autant d'argent que possible pour me protéger
du monde à venir que je suis en train de créer en gagnant cet argent ainsi ».
(Rires)
Ils peuvent porter autant de lunettes de réalité virtuelle qu'ils souhaitent,
peu importe le monde féérique auquel ils accèdent,
ils ne peuvent pas externaliser l'esclavagisme et la pollution causés
par la production des équipements posés sur leurs yeux.
Ça me rappelle le monte-plats de Thomas Jefferson.
On pense souvent qu'il a inventé le monte-plats
pour épargner ses esclaves le labeur de monter les escaliers
pour servir les plats à ses invités.
À tort, car ce n'était pas pour les esclaves.
Il s'agissait d'épargner à Jefferson et ses convives
la vue des esclaves qui apportent les plats.
Les mets arrivaient comme par magie,
comme matérialisés par un réplicateur dans Star Trek.
Ça fait partie du principe qui affirme
que les humains sont le problème et la technologie la solution.
Cette philosophie est caduque.
Arrêtons d'utiliser la technologie
pour optimiser l'humain par rapport au marché
et optimisons la technologie par rapport à l'avenir de l'humanité.
Ces jours-ci, c'est une proposition audacieuse
car les humains ne sont guère populaires.
J'ai tenu les mêmes propos récemment à une environnementaliste
et elle m'a demandé pourquoi je défendais les humains.
« L'homme a anéanti la planète. Il mérite de disparaître. »
(Rires)
Même les médias populaires détestent les hommes.
Regardez la télévision :
toutes les émissions de SF montrent les robots
sous un jour meilleur que l'homme.
Les films de zombies ? De quoi s'agit-il en fait ?
Un type observe l'horizon, un zombie traverse son champ de vision.
Zoom sur le visage du type
et vous savez ce qu'il pense :
« Quelle différence entre moi et le zombie ?
Il marche, je marche.
Il mange, moi aussi.
Il tue, moi aussi, je tue. »
Mais c'est un zombie.
Vous en êtes conscient.
Quand on n'arrive plus à distinguer un zombie de nous-mêmes,
on a un souci, et pas un petit.
(Rires)
N'évoquons même pas le transhumanisme.
J'ai participé à un panel sur le sujet et un type parlait de la singularité :
« Le jour est proche où les machines seront plus intelligentes que l'Homme.
Il ne restera qu'un seul choix à l'Homme :
transmettre le relai de l'évolution à notre successeur
et disparaître à l'horizon.
Au mieux, on pourra peut-être télécharger notre conscience sur une puce
et accepter notre extinction. »
(Rires)
J'ai répondu ceci : « Non, l'homme est particulier.
On accueille l'ambiguïté, on comprend le paradoxe,
on est conscient, bizarre et excentrique.
Il devrait y avoir une place pour l'homme dans l'avenir numérique. »
Le type m'a dit : « Oh, Rushkoff,
tu dis ça parce que tu es un homme. »
(Rires)
Comme s'il s'agissait d'arrogance.
OK, j'appartiens à « l'équipe humaine ».
C'est l'intuition première de l'ère numérique.
Être humain est un sport d'équipe
et l'évolution est un acte collaboratif.
Même les arbres d'une forêt,
n'entrent pas en compétition,
ils sont reliés par un vaste réseau de racines et de champignons
qui leur permet de communiquer et d'échanger des nutriments.
L'humanité est l'espèce la plus évoluée
car notre évolution principale fut dans la collaboration
et de la communication.
Nous avons le langage verbal.
Nous avons les technologies.
C'est étrange car auparavant, je parlais de l'avenir numérique
aux gens qui ne s'y connaissaient pas.
Maintenant, j'ai l'impression d'être le dernier survivant
qui se souvient ce à quoi la vie ressemblait avant le numérique.
Il ne s'agit pas de rejeter le numérique ou les technologies.
Il s'agit de conserver les valeurs que nous risquons d'abandonner
et de les intégrer
au sein des infrastructures numériques du futur.
Ce n'est pas de la physique nucléaire.
C'est aussi simple que de faire en sorte que les média sociaux
ne nous montrent pas comment voir l'autre comme un adversaire
mais qu'ils nous enseignent comment considérer l'adversaire comme un homme.
Ça signifie façonner une économie
qui ne favorise pas le monopole d'une plateforme
en extrayant de la valeur des gens et des lieux
mais qui promeut la circulation des valeurs à travers une communauté
et nous permet d'établir des plateformes coopératives
qui redistribue la propriété aussi largement que possible.
Ça signifie la création de plateformes
qui ne répriment pas créativité et innovation au nom de la prédiction
mais qui les promeuvent,
pour nous encourager à trouver des solutions
pour nous extraire des sables mouvants où nous nous sommes mis.
Plutôt que de mettre suffisamment d'argent de côté pour nous protéger
du monde que nous avons créé,
pourquoi ne pas consacrer notre temps et notre énergie à créer un monde
dont nous n'éprouvons pas le besoin de nous échapper.
Il n'y a pas d'issue de secours, il n'y a qu'un seul acte.
Ne quittez pas le navire.
Rejoignez-nous.
Nous ne sommes pas parfaits
mais quoi qu'il arrive, vous ne serez pas seul.
Rejoignez « l'équipe humaine » !
Trouvez l'autre.
Ensemble, façonnons l'avenir que nous avons toujours souhaité.
Voici ce que j'ai répondu aux milliardaires qui voulaient savoir
comment maintenir le contrôle de leur personnel de sécurité
après l'apocalypse :
« Commencez par traiter votre personnel avec bienveillance et respect.
Votre inquiétude sur l'apocalypse pourrait être vaine. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)